CNN
was talking about what's going on with
the election and this is interesting
because they're now showing that a bunch
of people and I look I not that I trust
CNN but here's some some interesting
polling a majority of Americans don't
want Trump or Biden that maybe we're
just moving past the old things
no repeats please that's the message
from voters in a brand new ABC News
Washington Post poll the survey Crystal
Clear take a look broad majorities of
Americans simply don't want Donald Trump
or Joe Biden back in the White House
come okay so that's interesting right so
most people don't want Trump don't want
to buy it and now look I happen to like
Trump do I like the santis more or do I
think that he would be a better standard
Bearer for the ideas I believe in and
that he has he done a bang-up job here
and is surrounded by the right people
and all those things yes I do but I
happen to like Trump and there are many
situations in which I could end up
supporting him and doing everything I
could to make sure that he would be
president and it would be far better
obviously than Joe Biden but the simple
truth is how old is Trump is 78 if I'm
not mistaken and Biden is now 79 or 80
even 81 these guys have to move on there
has never been a generation in Modern
Times Like These Boomers who will not
move on Gen X the people who are
basically somewhere between let's say 35
and probably late 50s I'm right in the
middle of that 46 are supposed to be in
charge right now but for some reason the
Hillary Clinton's and the Nancy Pelosi's
and the Mitch McConnells and the Donald
Trumps and the Joe Biden's and the list
goes on and on they will not get out of
the way I think there's there's
philosophical reasons for that and
existential reasons for that and there's
all sorts of reasons for that it's a
it's a system that caters maybe to
people holding on forever but it is time
to move on
[Music]
foreign